ja wir kommen zur dritten sitzung in der
wir uns mit ganz begriff der praktischen
freiheit befassen wollen
wir haben ist dieser sitzung mit
folgenden fragen zu tun was versteht
kann unter autonomie in der grundlegung
zur metaphysik der sitten
inwiefern knüpft die kritik der
praktischen vernunft an kannst tritt er
an den omi in der kritik der reinen
vernunft an also in dieser kredite ein
vernunft hat mir der letzten sitzung
behandelt nach oben rechts angehen kann
da können sie mal schauen was kant dort
zur freiheit problematik gesagt hatte
inwiefern setzt die kritik der
praktischen vernunft diese die kritik
der einfach voraus und wir haben doch
eine frage inwiefern vertritt kant ein
kompatibles muss von freiheits
kausalität und natur qualität das war ja
auch die große frage
die ist nach wie vor strittig da gibt es
eine riesen debatte in der forschung ob
jetzt kann ein kompatibel ist ist oder
nicht das ist übrigens ein sehr gutes
thema für eine mögliche hausarbeit das
mal genauer zu analysieren dann zum
schluss welche freiheits theoretischen
probleme ergeben sich aus ganz theorien
von freiheit als autonomie
das ist vor allem für die jetzt
folgenden debatte ab der nächsten
sitzung von zentralem interesse ja
immanuel kants ursache aus und
grundlegung zu mit hat sich der sitten
ist ein werk das er zentrales und
natürlich auch noch oder vor allem die
kritik der praktischen vernunft die
halte ich noch für viel wichtiger als
die grundlegung zur metaphysik der
sitten obwohl in dieser grundlegung zum
ersten mal kann es begriff der autonomie
eingeführten auch definiert wird und
obwohl dieses werk immer mehr auch
gelesen wird es eben kürzer ist es
kompakte aber systematisch ist die
kritik der praktischen meinen augen viel
wichtiger als eben das direkte
gegenstück oder der direkte fortsatz zur
kritik der reinen vernunft ist gut jetzt
haben wir es hier zu tun mit einem
kapitel aus der grundlegung zu metallica
sitten über die autonomie des will
als oberstes prinzip der sittlichkeit
sie sehen schon autonomie und
sittlichkeit sind bei kann zählen einmal
aufeinander bezogen kann zeigt jetzt
völlig gehen jetzt nicht alles direkt
durch habe ich will nur ein bisschen die
wichtigsten sachen hier in diesem text
darstellung unterstreichen also er sagt
die autonomie des wählens wissen
beschaffenheit des willens wodurch
derselbe ihm selbst unabhängig von aller
beschaffenheit der gegen stellt des
wollens ein gesetz ist das prinzip der
autonomie ist also nicht anders zu
wählen als so dass dem maximen seiner
wahl in demselben wollen zugleich als
allgemeines gesetz mit begriffen sein so
das ist natürlich ein imperativ sie
kennt es diesen dem allgemeinen gesetz
das ist ganz klar der kategorische
imperativ und ich will das jetzt mal so
ein bisschen hervorheben also die
autonomie des willens
das ist ihm selbst ein gesetz mit diesem
stift geht es doch schon viel besser es
ihm selbst eingesetzt und zwar
unabhängig
das ist wieder hier die negative
freiheit nämlich die freiheit von bremen
von den gegenständen des wollens also
der wille kann eben auch fast gerichtet
sein
was eben nicht ihnen dann autonom
bestimmte namen passen
das ist zum beispiel das ist zum
beispiel lust ist so ein gegenstand des
wohnens und das soll ausgeschlossen
werden sondern es soll allein das
allgemeine gesetz die form des allgemein
gesetzes soll ihn bestimmen und dann ist
autonom zu nennen ja also das ist jetzt
hier die erste einführung der der
autonomie
jetzt gehen wir mal weiter was kann
noch sagt nächsten zitat das ist der
dritte abschnitt übergang von der mitte
sitzen zur kritik der rein praktischen
vernunft der begriff der freiheit ist
der schlüssel zur erklärung der
autonomie des medians also jetzt haben
wir hier die frage nach dem verhältnis
von freiheit und von autonomie ja wie
ist denn da ist das dasselbe ja häufig
wird gesagt
freiheit ist autonomie oder freiheit als
autonomie ja also ich würde sagen der
begriff der freiheit der verweist jetzt
zunächst mal auf die kritik der reinen
vernunft
die hatten wir es ihnen sich mit
transzendentaler verleitete
transzendentale freiheit und dann hatte
kant noch unterschieden die praktische
freiheit freiheit und freiheit da ging
es um den willen bzw um die willkür
also da geht es dann um das handeln
praxis heißt das handeln das trans
sinntal bedeutet es ganz schwierig kann
sagt die bedingung der möglichkeit von
erkenntnis war immer ich würde sagen in
diesem sind zentrale freiheit ist eben
die grundstruktur das ist diese
kausalität aus freiheit würde ich jetzt
sagen das wird mit der trans zentralen
freiheit sehr eng verbunden und die
praktische freiheit die betrifft dann
ihr die verweist auf die autonomie weil
es hier um den willen geht und nicht
mehr nur um eine kausalität oder um ja
die vereinbarkeit von natur und
freiheits qualität sind hierbei der
autonomie wird es ganz konkret da
spielen die begriffe wie 'können' wille
eine große rolle
ja so viel zu diesem titel jetzt sagt er
hier eine ganz berühmte bekannte
definition sagte der wille ist eine art
von kausalität lebende wesen sofern sie
vernünftig sind und freiheit würde
diejenige eigenschaft dieser kausalität
zeit also kam solid es wichtig die da
sie unabhängig von fremden sie bestimmt
den ursachen wirken sein kann
fremd was ist natürlich klar das ist die
heterogen
das soll ihren die nicht nur eines
sondern nicht von dieser zu diesen
fremden faktoren abhängig sein
unabhängig sein das will ich negativ
freiheit sowie natur notwendigkeit die
eigenschaften qualität aller vernunft
los gewesen durch den einfluss fremder
ursachen zur tätigkeit bestimmt werden
also es geht um eine bestimmte
kausalität und die kausalität können sie
sich denken das ist natürlich die
kausalität aus freiheit aus
das ist die freiheit die kausalität von
der kant jetzt hier spricht und hier
sehen sie jetzt schon das kann den zug
zur kritik der einfachen und herstellt
durch den qualitätsbegriff mit der trans
zentralen feier
die angeführte erklärung der freiheit
ist negativ sagt er hier und daher um
gewesen ein zehnten und furchtbar
alles fließt aus ihr ein positiver
begriff derselben als sie haben das
damit der positiven freiheit zu tun
negativen positive freiheit der desto
reichhaltiger nur furchtbare ist da der
begriff eine kausalität den von gesetzen
bei sich führt gesetze nach welchen
durch etwas was wir ursachen etwas
anderes nämlich die folge gesetzt werden
muss so ist die freiheit ob sie zwar
nicht eine eigenschaft des willens nach
naturgesetzen ist darum doch nicht gar
gesetzlos sondern musste mir eine
kausalität nach und wandelbaren gesetzen
aber von besonderer sein denn sonst wäre
ein freier wille ein und die also es
geht um eine besondere qualität und das
ist wieder die qualität aus freiheit
die kant so ganz allgemein formal hinter
kritik der reinen vernunft entwickelt
hatte denk möglich erwiesen hat erst
denken so jetzt geht es weiter die natur
notwendigkeit war ein harter und wieder
wirken ursachen denn jede wirkung waren
nur nach dem gesetz möglich dass etwas
anderes die wirken die ursache zur
qualität bestimmt was kann denn wohl die
freiheit ist wenn sonst zeit als
autonomie
das heißt die eigenschaft des willens
sich selbst ein gesetz zu sein
hier haben wir jetzt ein ganz wichtiges
zitat hier bestimmt kennt jetzt freiheit
was kann denn nur freiheit des willens
ist autonomie
das ist also eine eine bestimmung eine
definition freiheit des willens ist die
autonomie und die wiederum ist die
eigenschaft als wenn sich selbst
angesetzt zu sein oder zu geben und das
gesetz ist eben das sittengesetz so
denkt jetzt kant autonomie also man
sieht hier schon kant fast hier freiheit
sehr eng mit moralität also moral also
freiheit wird verständlicher durch
autonomie und autonomie wird
verständlicher durch das sittengesetz
und hier unten sagt er das noch mal
welches gesetz er genau meint er meint
das prinzip nachdem keiner anderen
maxime zu handeln als die sich selbst
auch als allgemeines gesetz zum
gegenstände haben kann und dies sagte
ist die formel des kategorischen
imperativ und das prinzip der
sittlichkeit also ist ein freier wille
und ein wille unterschiedlichen gesetzen
einerlei so das ist jetzt dieses dieses
oder kriegen letzten mal das ist jetzt
so ein zitat was diese markante debatte
provoziert hat ja wie ist das zu
verstehen ist dieses einerlei zu
verstehen ist jetzt ein freier wille und
ein wille unterschiedlichen gesetzen
selbe wie kann man unter verstehen ja
also das sind solche solche fragen wie
eben wie man eben das verstehen muss
unter kant verschiedenes bedeuten unter
kann bedeuten geben also praktisch
sitten gemäss praktisch moralisch es
kann aber auch bedeuten nur als
moralisch gut es kann aber auch heißen
moralisch orientiert also im ersten
szene wäre wäre das hat so zu lesen also
ist ein freier wille und ein moralischer
tabelle dasselbe
das führt jetzt schon diese leser hat
führt zum intelligenten fatalismus das
ist eine these die hat der carl
christian ehrhardt schmid vertreten nach
kannte hat gesagt freie handlungen sind
nur handlungen die gute handlung sind
böse handlung sind nicht frei nur gute
handlung sind fragen also kann man
dieses unter verstehen man kann es aber
auch sehr bestimmt unterschiedlichen
gesetzen eben dass sie am kategorischen
imperativ orientiert sind dass man sich
aber auch dagegen entscheiden kann also
nicht weiß was gutes deswegen steht der
wille unter dem gesetz aber er ist jetzt
ganz unterworfen sein
er kann ihm auch sich kann sie auch
dagegen entscheiden die person hat auch
das wäre in einem gewissen sinne unter
die im siebten gesetz zu nennen
ja so viel zu diesem zitat ganz wichtig
das ist so die definition der autonomie
hier sagt er noch mal ein allgemeines
gesetz ich zugeben dass
und jetzt kommen wir arbeiten in meinen
augen wichtigsten schriften nämlich die
kritik der praktischen vernunft 1788 und
hier sagt jetzt kann die autonomie des
willens ist das alleinige prinzip aller
moralischen gesetze und der ihm gemäßen
pflicht alle hetero nami der willkür
könnte dagegen nicht allein gar keine
verbindlichkeit sei ist wie mit dem
prinzip des unterschiedlichkeit des
plans entgegen
in der unabhängigkeit nämlich von aller
materie des gesetzes nämlich einen
begehrten objekte das ist zum beispiel
lust unlust und zugleich doch bestimmung
der weg durch die plose eigen meine
gesetzgeber form deren eine maxime fähig
sein muss besteht das allgemeine
alleinige prinzip der sittlichkeit ja
alles soll hier sehen wir wieder das
autonomie und sittlichkeit oder
moralität ganz in aufeinander bezogen
sind und noch nie und moralische gesetze
das ist ziemlich eng verbunden und hier
setzt die nach ganze debatte an und die
versucht das etwas aufzutrennen
also freiheit und autonomie muss nicht
immer moralisch sein
wir können auch aus freiheit
unmoralischen und hier ist schon so eine
stelle die dann der folge sehr viele
diskussionen auslösen sollte ja das sagt
er
jetzt gibt es noch mal diese
verschiedenen negative freiheit positive
freiheit und das moralische gesetz
drückt die autonomie des willens aus und
das ist wiederum die freiheit das hatten
wir schon gesehen der grundlegung
kritisierten dass er diese drei begriffe
freiheit sittlichkeit und autonomie sehr
in einer beziehung setzt deswegen auf
einander beziehen
ja hier kommt noch ein wichtiges zitat
dass es aus einer fußnote aus einer sehr
bekannten fußnote hier sagt dass die
frau
die ratio cognos 10 die des moral ein
geschätztes ist das moralische gesetz
aber die ratio also das handy und das
moralische gesetz aber die nazis also
cognos zehnte freiheit sein
was bedeutet es dass die freiheit ist
der erkenntnis der science grund fürs
handy der science grund des moralischen
gesetzes also wenn die freiheit nicht
wäre dann wäre auch das moralische
gesetz nicht also die freiheit fungiert
irgendwie das moralische gesetz und das
moralische gesetz ist die erkenntnis
grund es wird deutet sich ein kopf und
das ende der freiheit das heißt durch
das moralische gesetz erkennen wir dass
wir frei sind weil wir eben auch anders
handeln können erkannte es gibt diese
formel von kant die heißt ungefähr du du
kannst weil du sollst ja also wer es
etwas soll der kann es auch wenn sonst
könnte er es nicht befohlen bekommt und
der kategorische imperativ fehlt uns
etwas
also müssen wir das auch können und dann
müssen auch das andere können also das
gegenteil können ja hier erläutert er
das noch mal den wäre dann wäre nicht
das moralisch gesetzen unseres und
deutlich gemacht so würden uns niemals
berechtigt halten das ist die rasse
cognos cent so etwas als freiheit ist
anzunehmen wäre aber keine freiheit so
wird das normale schicke setzen uns gar
nicht anzutreten zeit das ist der
science grund ihres handy
das ist ein ganz wichtiges zitat und
gibt sagt kant in einem anderen zitat
dass diese freiheit und moralisch gesetz
aufeinander
verweisen und sich gegenseitig bedingen
ja und hier ist noch eine wichtige
fußnote auch zu beginn der kritik der
praktischen vernunft sagte er folgendes
die vereinigung der kausalität als
freiheit die er als natur mechanismus
davon der erste durch siebtens gesetz
die zweite durchs naturgesetz und zwar
in einem und demselben subjekte der
mensch feststeht ist unmöglich ohne
diesen in beziehung auf das erstere
nämlich als freiheit als wesen an sich
selbst auf das zweite als erscheinen
jedes im rhein und dieses im empirischen
bewusstsein vorzustellen ohne dieses ist
der widerspruch der vernunft mit sich
selbst unter leidlich und hier möchte
ich noch mal hinweisen auf ein wichtiges
wort nämlich sie können sich denken auf
die vereinigung
es geht also um die kompatibilität
könnten nutzer von freiheit oder
freiheits qualität mit naturgesetzlich
kann und das könnte man jetzt ein eine
kompatibilität nehmen könnte es auch ein
kompatibles muss nennen
jedenfalls er kann diese kompatibilität
diese vereinbarkeit der ja in der kritik
der reinen vernunft wenn wir diese trans
zentrale unterscheidung einführen von
wesen an sich selbst das alles dinge an
sich selbst das ding wie es eben nicht
nur die erscheinung ist dass wir da rein
vernunft ist und eben der erscheinung
und dazwischen müssen wir unterscheiden
und auf diese unterscheidung da
grundsätzlich kann das gesamte freiheits
theorie und auch seine gesamte
erkenntnistheorie ja wir müssen
natürlich jetzt genauer verstehen was
das wesen an sich selbst ja das ist
bekannt später sein wird dir eine
praktische vernunft
hier eine praktische teil dafür dass
hinauslaufen dass das wesen an sich
selbst was nicht erscheinung ist
irgendwas mit rainer also wohl
empirischer vernunft zu tun hatten ja
soviel dazu ich wollte einfach mal
zeigen dass ich hier von vereinigung
spricht ja hier spricht ihr nochmals von
hetero- no meter wilken und autonomie
der willkür dieses zitat kann
überspringen und jetzt kommen wir zum
schluss dass sie diese ganz ganz
wichtigen kritischen beleuchtung der
analytik der rein praktischen vernunft
analytik ist bekannt immer ein system
teil
es gibt immer im analytik und dialektik
und die analytik hat es immer mit
grundsätzen zu tun und die dialektik hat
ist immer mit dem schein zu tun der
vernunft und das ist jetzt aus der
analytik der kritik der praktischen
vernunft und hier ist noch mal wichtig
dass kant jetzt auf diese trends
zentrale kausalität zentrale freiheit
eingeht und zwar so dass er sagt wenn
man eben die bestimmung der existenz der
die in der zeit bestimmen die die an
sich selbst annimmt also immer nicht
zwischen ging an sich und erscheinen
so lässt sich die notwendigkeit im
kursaal verhältnisse das ist die natur
qualität mit der verein auf keine weise
vereinigen hier haben wir wieder so ein
indikator für einen gewissen kompatibel
ist muss ja alles muss praktisch eine
form von vereinbarkeit geben die aber
basiert auf der unterscheidung von ding
hat sich und von
und das was er hier macht ist jetzt ein
argument zu geben was in der
gegenwärtigen debatte
von peter von wegen das ist ein
analytischer philosoph sehr prominent
vertreten wird dass das so werden den
konsequenz argument und ich mache oben
rechts im video zu einem vortrag von ihm
an der lmu hatte den mal gegeben und
immer auch noch oben rechts ein link
rhein zu einer sind in aussetzung der
wir uns in einem vergangenen semester
mit seiner philosophie befasst hat und
jetzt sagt er mir mit dass das
konsequenz argumenten aus der ersteren
folgt die notwendigkeit die
größenverhältnisse das aus der erfolg
dass eine jede begebenheit folglich jede
handlung die in einem zeitpunkt da
vorgeht
unter der bedingung dessen was in der
vorhergehenden zeit waren notwendig
seien dann nun die vergangene zeit nicht
mehr in meiner gewalt ist so muss jede
handlung durchaus über durch bestimmte
gründe die nicht in einer gewalt sind
notwendig sein das heißt ich bin in dem
zeitpunkt in dem ich handle niemals frei
das können wir uns folgendermaßen
vorstellen
also wenn jetzt meine zeitliche
lebensdauer sich zu erstreckt und das
ist derzeit strahlen
ich werde hier natürlich immer bedingt
kausal diese causa punkte seien die
qualität das problem ist nur die punkte
reichen weiter zurück als mein lebens
beginnt ja also folgt zwar dass auch das
und deshalb das so lange ich noch schon
lebt aber das eben da und da und da und
deswegen ist eben etwas was mich
bestimmt mittelbar jedenfalls nicht in
meiner gewalt weil es einfach vor meiner
existenz schon seinen grund hatte und
das ist das konsequenz ab
von peter von ihm wegen was erst später
so genannt hatte das ist so diese
gängige argumentation der inkompatibel
ist also der vertreter der these dass
freiheit und der termination nicht
vereinbar sind ist das standardargument
ja hier wieder diese unterscheidung von
ding an sich und erscheinung das kann
man springen
jetzt zeigt der folgende das eben wenn
man die freiheit retten will
so bleibt kein weg übrig als das dasein
eines dinge sofern es in der zeit
bestimmte ist folglich auch die qualität
nach den gesetzen hat tun wenn ich kein
bloß der erscheinung die freiheit aber
eben dem wesen als die man sich bei zu
nehmen ja das ist wieder bekannt so oft
immer wieder betont die trans zentrale
unterscheidung die ist eine ganze
theoretische und praktische philosophie
begründet und ihr spricht ja noch mal
wenn man sie als in ein und derselben
handlung nämlich die beiden
qualitätsdaten vereinigt also diese
vereinigung selbst erklären will nochmal
vereinigung es geht ihm ganz wichtig
ganz prominent um vereinigung die beiden
qualitätsdaten müssen vereint werden
und das ist für mich ein grund ihn ein
kompatibel ist zu nennen können ihnen
auch ein vereinheitlichung denker nennen
aber warum nicht kompatibel ist
natürlich ist dem hilft es kompatibel
ist muss er wieder sehr viel deutlich
aber das könnte für mich so eine art
beweis sein oder belegt sind dass er
doch ein kompatibles ja und jetzt zeigt
er was ganz interessant ist das noch mal
seinen kompatibles muss etwas besser
belegt das ergibt nämlich beispiel wenn
ich von einem menschen der einen
diebstahl verübt sage diese tat sei
nachdem naturgesetze der kausalität aus
den bestimmungen der vorhergehenden zeit
ein notwendigen erfolg also dass
konsequenz argument so war es unmöglich
dass sie hat unter bleiben können wie
kann denn die beurteilen
dem moralischen gesetze hier in eine
änderung machen und voraussetzen dass
sie durch unterlassen werden können weil
das gesetz sagt dass im gesetz sie hätte
unterlassen werden sollen das heißt wie
kann derjenige in dem selben zeitpunkt
in absicht auf dieselbe handlung ganz
frei heißen in welchem und in derselben
absicht jedoch unter einer
unvermeidlichen natur notwendigkeit
steht ja das ist die entscheidende frage
und diese frage stellen sich alle
denkerin und denker die sich eben mit
der frage an kompatible lesen muss und
inkompatibel ismus befassen in dem
selben zeitpunkt kann dieselbe handlung
ist das geht also dass diese derselbe
bezogen die selber ganz freiheit heißen
in welcher er auch unter einer
unvermeidlichen natur notwendigkeit
besteht also dass selben zeitpunkt ist
dieselbe handlung nämlich der diebstahl
vollkommen durch das naturgesetz
bestimmt und er ist auch vollkommen
falsch und das ist so der witz von kants
freiheitsbegriff er denkt dem
naturgesetz begriff determinismus
maximal start und er denkt auch den
freiheitsbegriff maximal starke und
häufig müssen kompatibel ist da wie zum
beispiel der jugend um freiheit mit
determination zu vereinbaren einen
niederschwelligen freiheitsbegriff
ansätzen dem nicht handlungsfähig und
nicht wie jetzt weit handlungsfreiheit
alles tun können was man will aber nicht
seinen eigenen willen noch mal bestimmen
können und kann sagt nein
kompatibel ist muss bedeutet für ihn
auch noch sein werden können und
zugleich völlig determiniert zu sagen
und das ist natürlich ein sehr sehr
starker vereins begriff darüber kann man
wunderbar hausarbeiten schneiden ganz
anderes thema jetzt bringt er hier noch
ein punkt und dabei möchte ich auch
bewenden lassen
es ist noch ein sehr sehr schönes zitat
hier spricht er jetzt von möglichen
ausflüchten das sind praktisch
kompatibel ist nun versuche von
kompatibel ist
und die könnten so argumentieren dass
man eben nur einen komparativen begriff
von freiheit ansetzt nachdem das
bisweilen frei bekommt heißt davon der
bestimmte natur und innerlich im
wirkenden wesen liegt zum beispiel das
was eingeworfenen körper verrichtet wenn
er in freier bewegung ist da man das
wort freiheit braucht weil er während
das er im flug ist nicht von außen
wodurch getrieben wird oder wieder
bewegung eine uhr auch eine freie
bewegungen weil sie ihren zeiger selbst
treibt also nicht äußerlich geschoben
werden darf ebenso die handlung des
menschen absichtlich durch ihre
bestimmungsorte in der zeit vorher gehen
notwendig sind dennoch freuen weil es
doch innere durch unsere eigenen kräfte
hervorgebrachte vorstellung sind dadurch
nach veranlassen den umständen erzeugte
begehrt und mithin auf unserem eigenen
belieben bewirkt der handlung sind
das wird also ein begriff von bloßer
handlungsfreiheit dass wir an
handlungsfreiheit wie david jung und
andrea im puristischen denken vertreten
hatte neben der grund ist uns aber woher
der grund wiederum kommt da fragen wir
nicht weiter der grund könne dann dort
auch wieder vermittelt von einem grund
außerhalb von uns kommen sie muss
irgendwas in uns liegen zum beispiel ein
trieb oder man könnte uns welche
begierden einpflanzen von außen dann
sind die briten zwei uns
aber wir sind nicht die autoren dieser
begierde und das wäre verkannt nur ein
komparative begriff und der wäre genauso
zu verstehen wie eine aufgezogene nur
die ja auch in sich irgendwie dieses
prinzip hat der natürlich von außen
jetzt aufgezogen werden musste um
loslegen zu können hat und das erkannt
das ist ein elender helfen ihnen dabei
helfen
also das ist praktisch kein gute keine
gute strategie
diese frage nach der vereinbarkeit von
freiheit und der termination unter druck
gesetzlichkeit zu lösen und dabei möchte
ich es mal bewenden lassen
das ist also diese spannende frage die
er in dieser kritischen beleuchtung der
analytik der kredite praktisch auf sich
nimmt
wie genau müssen wir uns jetzt uns
denken damit wir nicht nur komparative
freiheit bekommen sondern trans zentrale
freiheit und das ist verkannt wie gesagt
diese ursprünglichkeit diese spontanität
nicht irgendwie den bestimmungsort audio
sich zu haben sondern den bestimmungsort
in sich selbst zu haben und das ist das
was kann auch eine kausalität aus
freiheit nennt gut dann möchte ich dann
wenden lassen und bis zur nächsten
sitzungen